[Music]
hi everyone my name is Mattie Pfeiffer
and I'm an engineering director for
Android machine learning it's really
great to be here with you today to talk
about how Android developers can use
machine learning to build great features
for Android users Android today has a
wide range of machine learning tools
available for everyone
designers to product managers to
engineers mobile developers and machine
learning experts alike now Android is a
platform and one of the ways you can
measure the success of a platform is
through the great things that you folks
build on top of it in Android machine
learning we measure our success by your
success today Android runs on 2.5
billion devices and a great many of them
are already using on device ml on device
machine learning is no longer a thing of
the future it is here right now today
now Google is an AFS company so we use
machine learning in lots of places for
example in look out it's an application
which helps which aims to help blind or
visually impaired people gain more
confidence by helping them understand
their physical surroundings we also use
machine learning extensively under the
hood of Android to optimize battery
usage and allow you to get more done on
a single battery charge for those of you
new to machine learning let's have a
quick recap why do we use machine
learning at all well machine learning
allows us to solve certain types of
problems in very elegant ways for
example say you had to write code to
detect if someone was walking
and if you had access to their speed you
could write a fairly simple bit of code
to say hey if the speed is less than a
certain threshold say four miles per
hour then this person must be walking
and not for example running extending
this to running seems straightforward
enough and if we wanted to cover biking
as well we just need to add another
boundary condition to our code and we're
pretty much done right right what about
other types of activities for example
golfing so if you think about it
golfing involves a lot of walking
there's also carrying and swinging a
bunch of clubs so how do we go about
describing that this is where machine
learning can help in traditional
programming we express rules in
languages such as Kotlin Java or C and
we then apply those rules to problems of
interest in machine learning the
paradigm is somewhat different instead
of writing a bunch of rules we take a
lot of label data like photos of people
engage in different types of activities
with corresponding labels for those
activities and if we feed this data to
our neural network it will learn the
business rules for us without us having
to define them and in fact machine
learning has proven to be remarkably
effective at solving many different
types of problems including for example
activity detection and right now you're
probably thinking well this must be
really complicated well in fact it's not
but we'll get to that in a minute
I've talked to you about how we use
machine learning at Google but it's
really exciting to see other Android
developers using machine learning
the tools that we've provided to build
really cool stuff a group of engineers
in Delhi built a cogniser it's an
application which measures the levels of
air pollution using your phone's camera
alone now it is pretty amazing that you
can detect the presence of particles
smaller than 2.5 micrometers using just
the camera and a neural network or two
then there's great up school it's a
learning app which allows you to get
answers to questions you need help with
by simply taking a photo of them with
your mobile phone now to be clear my
school days are long gone but I'm a
parent I have seven year old twins and
it is absolutely awesome that they have
this type of technology available to
them as they go through school my family
and I live in London but I spend a lot
of time in California where everyone
seems to be a wine expert so to help me
take part in conversations about wine
I have Vivino it to uses machine
learning to help you explore good wine
with good friends but why on device
machine learning specifically well there
are several reasons for one we have
privacy a topic that's very important
both to ourselves as well as to our
users in many cases it's more
appropriate to just keep everything on
device so we don't have to worry about
how the data is processed in the cloud
on device machine learning works when
there is no connectivity or when the
network is patchy and if like me you
spend any time on underground trains you
will know that this is pretty useful
stuff by running our processing on
device we can remove Network latency out
of the equation altogether
and couple this with the latest
advancements in hardware acceleration
and we can give users truly real-time
experiences across a wide range of
Android devices in fact we have built
this capability into the Android OS
itself with the neural networks API
applications using tensorflow can
achieve great performance by
accelerating their workloads on
different types of hardware like GPUs
DSPs and NP r--'s and with Android q the
neural networks API will be able to
support even more great new use cases
with even better performance we have
worked really hard with our ecosystem
partners to achieve this and we're very
proud of the results for example on a
mediatek helio p90 we're able to achieve
a 9x increase in performance when
running ml kits face detection model but
it's not only about speed power
consumption is equally as important and
on qualcomm's snapdragon 855 AI engine
we are able to achieve a 4x increase in
energy efficiency when running very
powerful text recognition models
available in google lens these are all
really impressive results but I did say
that this was going to be easier than it
looks so let's get to that we have made
great machine learning tools that will
make you feel like a machine learning
expert first we are launching the people
plus AI guidebook a framework which
helps you explore machine learning
opportunities for your application in
Android platform we have made available
wonderful machine learning tools from
speech to computer vision then we have
ml kit
if you want to leverage google smarts
out-of-the-box then m/l kit is the
product for you google clouds auto ml
allows you to bring your own data set
and it will train a machine learning
model for your specific use case and
what's new this year is that this model
can be downloaded and run on device and
last but not least tends to flow put the
full power of machine learning at your
fingertips in an easy-to-use way clearly
there's lots to talk about so let's get
started hi will walk us through our
people plus AI guidebook come on up boy
Thank You Betty
hi everyone I'm Hawaii I come from the
Android developer relations team and I
lead our machine learning effort and if
you want to follow me on twitter my
handle is hoi tab hita be to get the
latest on njoy ml so when I'm speaking
to developers from around the world what
is the most common question that I get
is it how many layers
I should put into my new network or is
it which MLK Day pi2 use actually is
this one Hey my boss have asked me with
some machine learning into our app can
you help fortunately yes we can and also
you actually know a lot of the answer
because machine learning is no different
compared to any other new technology
think about the first time when material
design was launched how did you work
with it you work with product designers
and engineering all combine to decide
hey what kind of problem which one is
solve with our product how does it fit
in within the user journey and finally
how do we actually implement it and it
is not a single effort you don't just do
machine learning take the box and say
yep we're done we don't need to do any
more machine learning it is a very
iterative process when you have a new
technology you want to test the boundary
a little bit you want to collaborate and
you want to see how the user really use
your product and it's not a set at this
i/o we're launching the people plus AI
guy book there are six different
sections to help you structure your
conversation with your designers and
product managers you can access it from
this URL one of my personal favorite
section of the new guidebook is this one
dealing with graceful failure we're all
good programmers here so I believe
thinking about edge cases is just part
of the job but with machine learning
what is different is those are no longer
edge cases when you have in the
conventional programming world when you
have yes or no button it's fairly easy
to deal with when user click yes or no
in the new machine learning well what
happened when a user say well actually
3:00 p.m. is not great does that mean
yes or does it mean no you need to think
through that process of how to deal with
errors and failures because because it
is part of the main flow and if we want
to find out more about this people plus
AI guidebook I would strongly encourage
you to do to go to this session at 1:30
tomorrow afternoon where Google design
team will share with you the content of
the guidebook as well as real world
usage of the guidebook and devices among
Google products next I want to talk
about the Android platform itself and
what we offer as part of platform in
particular I want to talk about two
api's or two sets of api is even so the
first one is to do a speech I'm sure
that a lot of you have seen it from the
keynote so let's switch over to my phone
so
is a little app that I put together and
it uses the Android platform API to do
speech location as well as reading it
back to me far the text-to-speech API so
fingers crossed this is a live demo
let's see if it works I'm really glad to
be here in California so so you can see
it dictates and let's see how it reads
back out to me I'm really glad to be
here in California yeah hey so it works
whoo-hoo all right
so this secret button here because what
I just demonstrated is English and today
English is just table steak for
dictation how about trying it in my
native Cantonese so let's try this
coming up oh ho go hang on Tiger fan huh
no get some that
[Music]
so what I've just set there is I'm
really happy to share my experience with
you and let's see how he reads it out
come yet no hago hing Tong bye Goff and
her hog is summed up totally works so
let's switch back to slide out API on
the google pick so three and many of you
might have the question of hey wick
where is this API is it party enjoy X
support library is it pop enjoy pie is
it even queue how come I didn't hear
about it at what's new for Android this
may surprise you because actually it
wasn't new so we launched this API for
text-to-speech ten years ago at Google
i/o in fact it's such a long time ago
that YouTube doesn't support uploading
any video that's longer than 10 minutes
so I strongly encourage you to check out
part 9 of the keynote during that year
because what you hear is really
fundamental improvement in the quality
of sound that comes back out and that's
what a beauty of Android is that we
never stop innovating so the API is that
you were using we just keep that updated
through time how about the speech
recognizer the dictation part that was
launched as part of API 8 enjoy folio so
this is actionable for you today your
users should be able to access both
text-to-speech asper a speech recognizer
so next how easy is it to implement this
so let's go through the seven steps I
went through with the speech recognizer
so the first thing that you'd need to do
is to create your own speech break
listener within that class there are
multiple abstract methods that you need
to implement and I will highlight three
of them the first one is on partial
result so as I was speaking to the phone
you see part of the results coming back
as I spoke and what that does is it give
you
user feedback that you are listening to
them and the Machine actually understand
what they're saying another thing that
you can do to give the user more
feedback is on RMS change which detects
the noise level around the phone so you
can display the variation in noise level
back to your user and show that you
really literally listening to them and
finally when you get the result in on
result you access the URIs at the top
confidence result by just going into the
first element of the array and there
you'll find the string that you're
looking for in addition an optional step
is you can also look at the other
results that the Machine was coming back
with so for example when I'm saying I am
the machine might come back with I post
a VM or I space a.m. you can access both
through this method in order to use it
you need to initialize your own speech
recognizer and after that you also need
to have a speaking intent we know these
options I would like to highlight two of
them first I would strongly recommend
that you enable partial result again
it's about giving your user feedback
that things are working second as here I
specify you can specify the language and
this is Cantonese and when you're ready
you just feed the intent into the
recognizer that you have created and
away you go
it's that simple seven steps next I want
to go through the camera API itself you
might ask hey what is going on why are
you talking about camera I thought this
is machine learning as many of us know
many machine learning use cases leverage
the camera in order to do analysis and
when I first started six months ago I
thought hey this is easy you know is
Android I know Android this is great let
me try it out and this happened to me
when I first low up my
sample it just say oh wait you're using
camera one why we deprecated it in API
21 why are you still using it
what's wrong with you and I go yeah you
know I work in Android dev rel I know
Android I will update a sample so I went
to camera two I went to the basic camera
to sample and I find this particular
class and go yeah I all I need to do is
understand it and I scroll I scroll I
scroll because is a thousand lines of
code and is I oh my word
I am so dumb I don't understand why
Google Jaime and actually after why I
find the confidence to talk to a lot of
developers and they also have the same
problem so thank you for those of you
that share my pain I am perhaps okay as
a developer so birthday in mine at this
Google i/o we are launching camera eggs
the support library is really to do two
things improve the ease of use so that
you don't need to have a thousand lines
of code and three hours of this session
to present it to you and the second
thing is to increase device
compatibility at launch will support
three use cases preview image capture
and my personal favorite image analysis
you can see where this is going right so
how easy it is I told you it's not that
was allowed codes so let me just present
to you the four steps that went through
to implement the image analysis use case
the first thing I did just like the
speech rate listener is to create an
analyzer in the red box is where you put
your ml code so that's prep that's our
analyzer in order to run it the next
step that I do is to create a
configuration object for the use case
here you'll notice that we basically
find how the threading is going to be
run in very simple terms and my personal
for
is this option acquire latest image how
often your pipeline in machine learning
is backed up because your frame can't
deal with all the number of images
coming through this solves the problem
by only giving you the latest image that
it has so you no longer need to do your
own code to say hey let's throw away the
next five image and let's go on get on
with the next air with the latest one
this automatically does it for you after
that you create a use case feeding in
the configuration and the analyzer that
you have put it together and last but
not least just feeding it into a
lifecycle owner just bind it at a
lifecycle like for example the app
Compaq activity or the fragments that
you love that's all you need to do is
that simple four steps I'm sure a lot of
you would be interested to find out more
and as a result we do have an extra
session we hae and 532 more more
tomorrow afternoon not tomorrow morning
similar afternoon where our team from
camera X will be presenting this info
and you can ask them the questions that
are in your mind with that I welcome Dom
to talk about ml Kip come on up Don
thank you hi hello everyone my name is
dawn Chen I'm a tech lead of MLK team
I'm your kid was launched one year ago
at last Google i/o what you may wonder
what has happened to America since its
launch how they adapted by our
developers was new and it was cool with
a market in next few minutes I will lead
you through these questions first of all
a little refresher of a market for those
people who are new to it MLK is Google's
machine learning SDK for mobile we bring
the best of Google machine learning
model onto mobile devices behind a
simple to use API consistent across both
Android and iOS it's aimed at the making
machine learning easy and democratizing
I will make it accessible to all the
mobile developers just because you need
to use machine learning it doesn't mean
you need to be a ml expert or a data
scientist with a PhD you shouldn't need
to worry about collecting data training
models tuning model and running into our
mobile device a milk it would take care
of all that for you since launch a year
ago ml kid has a strong start and a
phenomenal growth his powerful models
combined with simple API have enabled
many mobile developers to add machine
learning feature onto their mobile apps
we're seeing user engagement
accelerating with active user sessions
growing by 60% month to month developers
are building really interesting mobile
apps with a market ranging from social
sharing app for fishing lovers to
shopping assistant apps for consumers of
shoes clothes and furniture they have
used a full range of AMOLED api's such
as per text recognition barcode scanning
image labeling etc our face detection
models are 18 times faster as compared
to the last Google i/o and 13 to 24
percent more accurate the addition we
also launched face count or a detection
besides the vision API s we have now
also expanded the natural language
processing we introduced the language at
infusion feature for detecting the
language based on the textual input we
also launched a smart reply for
producing meaningful responses for a
casual chat if this piece API is doesn't
fit your need we also support hosting or
running custom models and we did not
stop here I'm thrilled to share that
we're now launching several exciting
features for a ml kit first of all we're
launching object detection our tracking
you can now use ml kit to detect single
and multiple objects yes that image the
addition you can track them in a
streaming video when your phone moves
this will be very useful for identifying
interesting items for further processing
and showing in this video using your
phone and milk' to identify and track
the potted plant in the room and with
that detection result the app will look
up the item and show you a product
headlock with prices and the links for
shopping similar items secondly we're
launching a market Hong device
translation API for the very first time
mobile developers had tapped into the
same model powering the offline Google
Translate app free of charge
the transition will run entirely on the
device your own app you can now add a
transition between any pair of languages
from 59 supported languages you will
also have a control over which language
packs to download when to download them
and the how long gonna keep on a mobile
device at last Google i/o we introduced
own device and cloud-based image
labeling API the on device API identify
hundreds of labels and the cloud API
identify more than 10,000 labels for
this beautiful photo using the UM device
API look at labels like a dog pad
Mountain this is a great but this
pre-trained Google models can only
provide generic classifications what if
I want to recognize my dog's name or
detect the dogs breed now will require
me to train my own custom model and for
that all ml is a powerful tool which can
help you with a model at research as
well as model training two years ago
Google launched the cloud-based automail
those powerful and the very large models
can only run on a server and doesn't fit
into the mobile device
what if I want all utilize the power of
automail at the same time also on to a
take advantage of the cost speed and
privacy benefits of own device machine
learning as Mateus discussed minutes ago
I'm excited share the green news with
you
now we're launching a market automail
vision edge it provides the same
easy-to-use image labeling API plus a
test flow light model customized for you
trained by automail you can now bring
your own images of the items your
interesting as little as our tens of
images per item depending on your
scenario we'll then train the classroom
model for you using the automail based
on the photos you provided and we'll
also find and tune the model with the
performance and size optimized for
mobile devices you generate a tense flow
line model customized for you and which
runs entirely on a device for example if
I want to build a mobile app I can
classify different type of flowers I can
use other mail to help me train the
model to do that I'll first use the
firebase Council of web interface to
upload the photos of flowers I have once
I've uploaded all the flower photos I'll
start training my own model and for each
training job I can choose the best
options that fit my requirements in
terms of inference latency translation
accuracy and model size the addition I
can choose how many hours the computer
hours I'm willing to spend on a training
that fits in my budget once the model
training complete will show you the
quality of the model in terms of
precision and recall rate now with the
model trained how do I use it in my own
app I milk it will help you with that
I'm going to show you one slide our
custom code which will implement a
flower classifier use the model we have
just trained first algorithm model with
named flowers then I will reach to the
flowers model with firebase model
manager the register remote model car in
the case model will be download remotely
from the firebase console and you me
worry about the model downloading a milk
it would take a lot for you you also
have the option to download the model
from firebase cancel yourself and bundle
it inside your app next I will specify
the options for using this flowers model
I will specify this confidence threshold
at 0.45 for my model depending on how
the model is trained with the option I
will then create my flower Leibler at
this ApS may look familiar to you
as they are really very similar to the
existing own device and the cloud image
labeler api's except now we're using a
model train by automail isn't that
beautiful
finally i can run my flower labeler to
detect and classify the flowers inside a
photo or a streaming video yay with this
a few lines of code I have build my own
flower classifier running a model train
by automail based on the photos I have
for those who are new to a market I
strongly encourage you to try it out you
will be amazed how simple yet powerful
it is last but not least we're launching
new mature design guidelines for ML use
cases on mobile machine learning has not
only added magic features mobile apps
but also affected more and more products
appearances to provide a great end to
end user experience we're publishing new
mature design guidelines to aim to make
an ml product experience usable
beautiful and understandable our object
detection tracking showcase app was
developed following all these guidelines
and its fourth source code is available
on github for both Android and iOS to
learn more about the American please
come
our session tomorrow at 12:30 we'll show
you some cool demos and walk you through
all the new features were launching and
to learn more about mature design for ml
please come to our session 12:30 on
Thursday with that I'll hand over to
Lawrence we'll talk about tests for life
thank you thank you so hi everybody
we've seen a lot of great stuff that's
available on Android we've seen how some
of the native API is and Android can be
used with machine learning and we've
also seen how ml kits can be used with
pre-existing models as well as building
your own models I'm gonna switch gears a
little bit and talk about tensor flow
and how tensor flow can be used for
building custom models that could be
deployed into ml kit or could be
deployed directly to your device who
here has never heard of tensor flow okay
I'm doing my job good one so going back
to what matei mentioned earlier on so
tensor flow is our API for building
machine learning and for running machine
learning models and going back to mattei
slides from earlier on the whole idea
around machine learning is I like to
think of it as a new programming
paradigm we're also for developers and
it's a new way for us to write code to
open up new scenarios and instead of us
thinking of the rules and expressing
them in code ourselves what if we could
actually label a bunch of data and then
have the machine in fair the rules that
make that actual data and that you know
if you come away with nothing else about
machine learning think about it in that
way so tends to flow the architecture of
tensorflow from a high level looks like
this you know on the left hand side of
this diagram are all the things that use
for building models and we tend to call
that training so there's api's in there
like chaos and estimators and this
distribution strategy if you're building
big complex models so you can spread it
across CPUs and GPUs that kind of thing
but then on the right hand side is
deployment so your models wants their
builts they can run in servers with tf-x
intensive low serving they can run in
the browser with sense flow j/s or on
node servers with sense flow Jas but
then what we're going to be talking
about today is tens flow light where you
can put it on mobile devices including
Android so I'm going to give a quick
demo if we can switch to the laptop
so here I've designed a simple
neural network that I could come up with
at the back if you cannot read this code
just go like that you cannot read it
okay I'll make it bigger or do you just
like doing this is that is that good if
you can read it go like this okay
so this is the simplest neural network I
could come up with where if you can
imagine your neural network is a series
of connected layers of these things
called neurons and so in this one I have
a single layer and it has a single
neuron in it so it's basically just a
simple function that calculates
something so I'm going to feed that with
a bunch of data and here's the
relationships between the data on here
my X's and my Y's
can anybody figure out what these data
are actually doing if you're on my
earlier talk you've seen this already I
know but the 0 and the 32 might be a
clue yeah it's Celsius to Fahrenheit
convertor when it's kind of given away
by the name F to see how I thought that
was French to Cantonese but so what I'm
gonna do is I'm just gonna give it a
bunch of data and then what a neural
network will do is it will iterate
across that data and figure out the
patterns between them so I'm gonna run
that I know we're short on time and the
party's coming up so let me run through
it quickly so it's gone through five
hundred iterations of trying to figure
out the pattern and at the bottom this
is so big I have to scroll forever and
then at the bottom I'll go on to this
node so if I for example pass it and a
hundred and a 100 degrees centigrade is
212 Fahrenheit if I run it I'm getting
211 point 3 because I only had a small
amount of data I only had 6 values and
it's given me a very high probability of
the relationship between those in the
two numbers being centigrade to
Fahrenheit so now I've built a model
it's a very very simple model but what
am I gonna do with it I want to use that
on mobile so we're tensorflow the first
thing that you have to do is you save it
out and we've got a format called saved
model which is used as a consistent
format across everything so I'm gonna
save this out as a save model with the
save Kerris model like this and when
that saves out hopefully if it does
after a bunch of warnings it's gonna
give me the path that it saved it to and
I'm gonna take that and this notebook is
online I'll share the code
for it in a moment and I'm gonna run
that in here and now what it's doing is
it's calling the TF light converter to
convert that model to TF lye and it's
given me a number here 620 can anybody
guess what that number is it's not an
HTTP code it's the size so that model
that I just built that's the size and
bytes so 620 bytes and I have a model
called TF lights
sorry called model TF light that has
been saved out of my temp directory and
it's right here so I can now download
that model and use that on Android
can we switch back to their slides
please so now that I have that model
this is the conversion process that I
went through I built an intense flow I
saved it out I used the TF light
converter and then I created a TF light
model out of that and here's the code
that I showed to do that this QR code is
the URI of the notebook that I just
showed so if you want to play with the
notebook for yourself it's on there so
now what runtime the model the the
diagram becomes we feed data into the
model and we get predictions out so what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna run this model
on mobile using Cartland so to be able
to do that first of all I deploy my
model to my Android device as a as an
asset file that asset filed again can be
just treated like any other assets in
Android now one thing that on Android
and the number one bug when I work with
people who use TF light one thing is
that when you deploy assets to Android
Android itself actually zips up those
assets it compresses them and TF light
won't be able to interpret it if it's
compressed so in your a apt options make
sure you say do not compressed EF light
then I in my builder cradle I just set
the implementation to give me ten to
float our lights are tense flow light
and now in my code I'm gonna do a couple
of things so first of all I have to
create an instance of a TF light
interpreter and something called a
mapped byte buffer the map byte buffer
what I'm doing said that's just reading
the model out of assets so that I can
create an instance of that model I'm
gonna set in the options the number of
threads I want the model to run on and
then the interpreter itself can then run
on those my code itself and I'm gonna
skip over this slide because we're
running at it
I'm just gonna show it in the demo so
can we switch to the demo machine please
so I have a very simple application
running in the emulator here this
application all it has is a single
button that says do inference but when I
click that I'm gonna get a breakpoints
and now here's the breakpoint with my
actual code so I want to pass the number
100 into the model and get back like 211
and change so that's the conversion of
one temperature to another so I've
created an array and it's just a simple
array with one element in it and that
element contains the hundred that I'm
passing in my output value is going to
be a byte buffer because the model is
gonna feed me back a stream of bytes
we're going really low level with this
but I know that those bytes are gonna be
a float and a float is four bytes so I'm
just allocating a byte buffer with four
bytes and then I'm gonna step through
this and I'm gonna run it and when I run
it I'm passing to tensorflow lights
interpreter the input value of my input
value array and then my output value
array where it's gonna write the answer
so it writes the answer into that and
now I can read the answer out of that by
just calling the get float of that byte
buffer and we'll see here in the debug
that it was 211 and change so it's a
very very simple example and it seems a
little bit complex with me using these
arrays and these byte buffers to do it
but the idea is that it's going to be
exactly the same code pattern that you
use for a far more complex example we
kind of just want to make it so that
it's consistent regardless of the
example that you use and I also want to
show a really cool new Kotlin language
feature here so if you see like on line
Android studio numbers my lines for me
and if you can see on it I have a line
57 has TF Lite don't run and actually in
Cartland I can then go go to 47 and it
will rerun it for me no not really I
think it was paying attention so if we
can switch back to the slides so that
was like a very very quick look at how
you would actually write that code and
host that custom model for yourself in
CF light so today we've actually seen
all of these options that are available
for you in Android and I'd like to
invite my
hey back up onto the stage to wrap us up
thanks Maya
thank you very much Lauren alright folks
there you have it
Android really has ml capability built
right into it and we have great tools to
help you take advantage of that the
people plus AI guidebook Android api's
ml kits exciting new features Auto ml on
device capability and if you want to
build your own tensorflow
is your friend we've also created a new
section on the Android developers
website which details our machine
learning offering across Google please
check it out at developer.android.com
/ml today is just the beginning for us
at i/o and we have many great talks
coming up which will go into more detail
about everything that you have heard
just now and finally if you have
questions my team and I will be in the
AI ml dome after this talk so please do
come and see us thank you so much for
being here with us today and enjoy the
rest of i/o
[Music]
you